quarterbacks on the hottest seats in
2020 the topic for today's draft no
trivia question chris i'm just going to
go ahead and give you in in deference to
your technological issues i'm going to
give you the first pick quarterbacks
with the hottest seats in 2020 europe
well it's very nice to you thank you i
appreciate it i am flustered
but i can't they they told me to okay
good i didn't think you were actually
capable of genuinely being nice and
giving me the first pick so that just
confirmed that that's good to know
okay here we go
uh i think it's gotta be the guy we just
talked about i mean i hate to draft him
as captain obvious but come on mitchell
trubisky i mean his butt's so hot he
might not even make it to the regular
season i mean of course we know they
didn't they didn't exercise his fifth
year option
you know the optics of the way he played
last year it was not good that he have
some good moments certainly you know but
there's a lot of issues and
inconsistencies in throwing decision
making you know again you've heard me
say he kind of falls into that that
category of a quarter a quarterback or
an athlete who's a quarterback instead
of a quarterback who's a good athlete
and there's a difference there but
trubisky yeah i think this is a real
competition and like i like i told you
and i think we agree on this i expect
nick foles if it's close to be the
starter week one i think that's a
smarter play for the chicago bears so
yeah i think trubisky's seat is very
high
see and i had that on my list as whoever
wins the starting job has the hottest
seat so i'm i'm
i'm not focusing on it as of right now
i'm focusing on it as of week one
whoever that guy is and it's probably
harder for trubisky if he wins it than
it is
but i think whoever you know we've seen
this before when you have a full-blown
quarterback competition the winner also
wins the right to be the first guy
benched because typically that's going
to happen at some point unless the team
just comes out of the gates on fire at
some point they're going to struggle and
at some point the coach is going to say
well maybe we should go with the other
guy and see if it gives us the kick that
we need but i agree with you between the
two it's harder for trubisky he's the
incumbent starter he may not be the
starter week one all right in las vegas
derek carr is the starter and the
raiders have brought in marcus mariota
at seven and a half million dollars to
be his backup that is a message that is
a shot across the bow we talked about
derek carr last week on the top 40
countdown the fact that there's never
really been this sense that the raiders
are all in with derek carr under john
gruden and mike mayok mayok repeatedly
says we look to upgrade at every
position on the team including starting
quarterback john gruden has from time to
time maybe seemed not as thrilled as he
could be with derek carr but it's not
like they've had a better option mariota
could end up doing dakar this year what
ryan tannehill did to mariota last year
in tennessee so i think it naturally and
inherently gives derrick carr a hot seat
going into the season and i think part
of what they want chris is to see how he
deals with that
agreed agreed and that certainly seems
to be the the perception the no doubt
about it you know derek carr for
whatever reason easy gotta jump on you
know and again yes like you just
mentioned
i think the the raiders kind of open up
the debate or the questions a little bit
to
uh to make the
life harder on derek carr certainly
they've kind of added scrutiny to him by
keeping the door open about always
keeping competition and yeah it just
doesn't it just feels like
they're yeah we like them but we don't
love them and we might be looking for
something better so i'm with you and i
don't even know if it's necessarily fair
it's not like they put a tremendous
amount of talent around derek carr the
last few years either i think though
this year with a little more talent
around him he might silence some of
these critics i would be shocked if
mariota could beat him out or take his
job i think derek carr will play at a
high enough level and he's just too much
of a a real quarterback and a gifted
thrower to let somebody like mariota
supplant him but it is it's going to
come down to him on the field can he
make plays and kind of silence you know
us critics out there to where they can
move on that conversation to something
else so
let me just say this let me say this
before you make your pick because it's
going to be a factor first five games
for the raiders at carolina saints at
the patriots bills at the chiefs bye
week that's going to be a factor when
they go into the bye week where are they
through those first five games how do
they feel about the team and you got
that bye week perfect opportunity to
make a switch if that's what they choose
to do but uh well
how they do those first five games is
gonna be a huge factor i think
yeah no definitely yeah i mean you're
right they're gonna have to come out
looking good on the offensive side of
the ball whatever it may be all right
my next pick i'm going to go with
gardner minshew yeah you know listen i
know he's like
the starter but he's going to have to
play well
for the whole year and prove that he's
like starting quarterback material to
keep that job you know i think there was
legitimate interest maybe in tula in the
draft we heard a lot of names thrown
around in free agency listen if i'm the
jacksonville jaguars
i'm still calling cam newton i don't
mean to say that to disrespect gardner
minshew but i just one thing i know in
life is that cam newton is better than
gardner minchu i'm sorry so uh yeah i
look at him as a guy that is going to
have to prove himself and play well this
year for jacksonville not to maybe look
for their quarterback in the future or
that franchise type quarterback so i
think his butt is kind of hot and he's
gonna have to perform at a pretty pretty
high level
and if he doesn't get it done this year
i think everybody's going to be gone
down there and he may fall out of favor
quickly with whoever the new regime may
be in 2021 right next one for me and the
evidence has been hiding in plain sight
ron rivera isn't a guy to play games or
mince words he's been ambivalent about
dwayne haskins they traded for kyle on a
guy who did a lot of good things last
year for a nice chunk of the season in
carolina after cam newton was injured
and if haskins isn't getting it done ron
rivera is not going to be bashful about
putting him on the bench and going with
kyle and alex smith is still kind of
floating around out there as a
possibility too but now i think that
haskins has responded well to the
pressure that rivera's already put on
him i don't think he's going to crumble
under this weight of expectation from
his coach and accountability and an ex
and just a a desire to see him live up
to that top 15 draft status but i think
the seat's hot i think he's going to
react well to it but i do think the
seat's hot
yeah i mean he's got talent he certainly
showed us a glimmer there at the end of
the year before he got hurt to go okay i
see it dwayne haskins here we go
hopefully you can take over but uh
you're right i think there is questions
that remain out there about him
certainly all right
man i was i wasn't sure where to go here
i mean i don't want to take ty rod
taylor or ryan fitzpatrick
i'm going with jimmy garoppolo
jimmy garoppolo i'm gonna take him yeah
i mean again i know the 49ers have been
saying all the right things shanahan
lynch and again i think jimmy garoppolo
i'd be shocked if it doesn't continue to
go on an upward arc but it doesn't make
you know up for the fact that do i think
he's gonna be extra scrutinized and his
seat is hot this year yeah i do i mean
obviously there wouldn't have been
conversations about tom brady if they
were just totally sold on garoppolo's
the guy he's the man going forward he's
the future let alone the way the
playoffs and super bowl played out so
you know i'm a believer in garoppolo but
i do think this is a big year and if
it's an underwhelming just so so year
and maybe the 49ers limp into the
playoffs or just miss it then i think
there could be some real conversations
about the quarterback position in san
francisco after the season's over
i specifically deferred him
so you would be the one to say jimmy
garoppolo oh thank you i didn't want to
pick them because now everyone's gonna i
know you did was chris sims talking to
kyle shanahan no nobody talked to kyle
we don't talk about crap like that this
is just i pay attention to football okay
i know but that's why i didn't take him
that's why i didn't take him i wanted to
see you all twisted up in knots all
right let's take a break i'll give you
my pick i get a little extra time
because i got two i can choose from
we'll give you my last pick when pfd
live continues right after this
all right my pick my final pick we don't
have a whole lot of time but chris i
want you to guess which two guys that
i'm i'm wrestling with for my pick
oh okay kirk cousins
no i'm going to
no okay i just thought maybe you would
see he's got a three-year fully
guaranteed contract now i'm not gonna
play this game with you baker mayfield
contract i mean he gets it he's a little
bit he got a new contract he got a new
contract chris you got to read
footballtalk.com
yeah i forgot it precipitated stefan
diggs saying i want out it won't all
happen the same day i'm gonna say baker
mayfield look this is year three for him
if he's the guy that he was last season
you got a new head coach there you got a
new gm there right
new coach wants his own quarterback case
keenum is there kevin stefanski working
with keenum almost got to the super bowl
i'm not saying it's blazing and i'm not
predicting that baker mayfield will be
bad enough to justify being benched but
if he gets banged up at all and it gives
a little crack for keenum and keenum
comes in and plays like he did in 2017
and get interesting in cleveland very
quickly i'm not predicting it'll happen
but i think there's a little flame there
when you got a new head coach you got to
prove to that head coach that you're
worthy of the job chris you got to prove
that you're the guy because if you're
not the coach is going to find somebody
else
yeah well and listen i agree with you
that if he got hurt in case kingdom got
got in it could be scary definitely
there's no doubt but i don't again this
is the number one pick in the nfl draft
i don't think cleveland's gonna make up
their mind after three years especially
after a great rookie year and then
decide to you know fold shop and move on
i don't think so but i hear what you're
saying mike it is scary with case keenum
behind him who we know we can capitalize
with the team around him
hey this is cleveland where three years
is like 30 years so
they make decisions a lot faster than
that about everybody in cleveland
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports